the day begins in dark ooh with the
arrival of the morning school boat the
children live on outlying islands in the
rail river delta lessons will begin soon
a drumbeat signals the start of school
today's lesson plan includes civics
don't wait for others to do something
for you think instead about how you can
be useful to the community otherwise
you're a silliest breadfruit community
is important here in dark uu a tiny
village in the southeast of Fiji's main
island Viti Levu the 400 some villagers
have a common problem it has become
nearly impossible to grow anything here
as a result of climate change
the river rises on a regular basis and
floods half the village that's why our
houses are on stilts the brackish water
rises from below we can't plant
vegetables because everything dies right
away it's become more extreme over the
past eight years recently a dam was
built to protect the village it was paid
for with government and international
aid without here we might have been
forced to move away we want to save the
village for our children and
grandchildren but how can the village
sustain itself the women of dark who
have found an answer and simultaneously
sparked a revolution for generations
they've been weaving fans out of palm
fronds their technique is a well-kept
secret
it's something sacred
a village that was granted to us by Viva
Luigi's first king we weren't ever
allowed to sell the fans but now with
climate change and the economic problems
our men requested permission from the
king and for the past few years we've
been allowed to sell them the fans are
sold for about three euros each and now
account for nearly 70% of dark whose
income financially the men of dark who
are now almost completely dependent on
the women it's a major change in their
lives until recently women and younger
villagers had little say the Fiji
Islands are still largely a
male-dominated society that's abundantly
clear at the several civil ceremony only
men get to drink the coveted kava root
grog it's bitter numbs the mouth and
it's considered a real delicacy the
drink is also said to be healthy the
woven fan initiative hasn't led to
greater social upheaval in the village
thanks to a gender equality training
program financed with German funding
villagers attended workshops where they
learned that they could solve their
economic problems better if the men and
women work together as equals the
women's representative tries to ensure
that the lesson isn't forgotten
but not everyone in the village is happy
when the bastions of male dominance are
threatened the school manager a
respected member of the community airs
his complaints for me gender has nothing
to do with equality the man should make
the decisions not the woman we know that
from the Bible the woman should obey and
serve the man that's the natural
god-given order and that shouldn't
change the men here have fished in the
rail River Delta for generations
these mangrove swamps were once swarming
with fish and shrimp but in many areas
deforestation has led to riverbank
erosion the water contains more sediment
the silt clothes the mangroves and
destroys the fish breeding places the
fishermen see the effects every time
they take their boats out the catch in
the fish traps is meager so the men now
regularly make trips to the fertile
island of khalili to collect palm leaves
for the fans everything that grows is
considered common property I bring
coconuts to eat back from the plantation
and branches that are used to make the
fans that's become our most important
source of income over the world it's a
well-organized supply system that gives
the men of dark ooh the opportunity to
contribute to the villagers success they
also help boil the fronds from the
coconut palms as husband of the women's
representative it's my job to support my
wife i seated the firewood in the water
and I'm very proud that she has this
important position glad you recognized
my word such examples of mutual respect
and not to be taken for granted in Fiji
meanwhile in dark ooh the villagers have
gathered for a celebration the highlight
is the Miki dance faces and bodies are
blackened with charcoal
here at least the young men of the
village can carry on male traditions
just like they did a hundred years ago